the latest data on cover 19 and there's
a bit of good news a glimmer perhaps
when you look at case numbers across the
uk just look at that latest
dot each of those dots by the way
showing you the number of cases we get
each day
announced each day 36 389 cases why is
that significant it's because it's a
third successive day that we've seen
those
coming down so potentially encouraging
and if we look at different measures of
how much covert there is
around the uk well look at this one for
instance this is incidents looking
at the amount of covert per hundred
thousand in england and that line
may look like it's going up into the sky
which it kind of is but if we convert
this to a logarithmic chart remember
we've been doing this throughout the
pandemic haven't we
it gives you a sense of growth rate so
the steeper the lines are uh the faster
things are growing
same data i should say and if we just
zoom in on that
latest line you can see maybe in the
last few days that growth rate has
potentially
slowed a little bit but bear in mind two
things we still have yet to see the real
impact of the unlocking the 19th of july
that's probably going to push
this line up even further and secondly
there are other measures of covert 19
they're not all
quite as encouraging have a look at this
this shows you this is the ons perhaps
the the most comprehensive of all the
measures
of covert and this line is still going
up in fact up to 1 in 75 people
in the weekend in july the 17th that's a
lot higher than it was only a few months
ago look back in april it's one in 600
people and why is it worth comparing
those two things well
that decision remember that decision
back in april about who was going to get
which vaccination and younger people
aged under 40 the preference was not
astrozenica for other things
other things instead pfizer moderna
because of those blood clots that we're
seeing
that's partly that calculus was partly
because cases were very low at that
point
have a look at this this is the chart
that best shows it on the left you've
got the benefits of the vaccine those
bars show you basically
your risk of going into intensive care
if you haven't been vaccinated get they
get bigger don't they as you get older
because that first bit at the top
is 20 to 29 year olds and on the right
hand side those red bits show you the
risk from the side effects so your
likelihood
of potentially getting a clot and you
can see the bars on the right are longer
than the bars on the left for the
youngest age groups
but now look what happens now when we've
got higher levels of covert 19 around
the country look at what happens to
those bars they
shift across because you've got a
greater risk
of going into intensive care even if
you're in those younger age groups so
that even those aged 20 29
have a risk 2.2 per hundred thousand of
going into intensive care compared with
1.9
uh per hundred thousand of getting one
of those blood clots so that whole
calculus has changed as the numbers of
covert 19 around the country
have gone up